(powerful dance music)
- What I feel when I am
dancing, I feel free.
I just feel confident, I feel strong,
I feel in control of who I am.
I knew this is what I wanted to do.
I didn't wanna do anything else but this.
It's crazy.
My name is Akira
Armstrong, and I am the CEO
and founder of Pretty Big Movement,
which is a full-figured,
professional dance company.
I started Pretty Big
Movement nine years ago,
and I felt that there was a void
in main-stream media,
where it wasn't a platform for plus-size,
professional dancers.
I didn't fit in.
Even when walkin' into auditions,
I didn't feel like I belong.
The typical expected body type is
the ballerinas, you know, the long legs,
the long arms, long torso.
It's upsetting that society
puts this label on dancers because for me,
it's about the talent.
I had booked this major gig with Beyoncé,
I decided, "Well, lemme audition
"for more representation."
I auditioned for at least
five different agencies, and they all kept
sayin' the same thing:
"She's good but we don't
know how to market her."
And I got tired of hearin' that.
Even though I struggle with things,
it was my passion.
It's somethin' that I wanted to do;
it's somethin' that I love.
And I kept pushing, kept
pushing, kept pushing.
And it just got to a
point where I was like,
“This is really what I wanna do."
We came up with the name Pretty Big
and from there I said,
"I need a pack a girls,
"who know how to move,
who know how to dance."
We have a range of young ladies
who are professional dancers,
they work hard to prove themselves,
not only to me but also to themselves.
Five, six, seven, here we go, and a one,
and a two, and a three, jump!
One thing is that we do,
is our Pretty Big Movement workshop.
Anybody is welcome to
come to our workshops.
I am pretty big, and I am powerful because
I feel nothin' but love in this room.
We do power circles and that portion
of the workshop becomes very emotional.
- Each and every day I'm
learning to love myself,
and those who tear me
down, can't keep me down.
- We've had people say,
"I've beat divorce,
"I've beat suicide; I was a rape victim."
- I beat cancer, so I
wasn't gonna let this foot,
keep me back!
- They just feel
comfortable enough to
just spill it all out.
The misconceptions that people have
about plus-sized women,
"We are lazy, we have low self-esteem."
We are built! (loud cheers)
"We don't care about our appearance,
"we are non-existent."
And we exist.
This is who I am!
Plus-size and fabulous! (giggles)